Der Rekord ist geknackt: Ein Forschungsteam
aus Michigan hat den kleinsten Computer der
Welt gebaut.
Seine Kantenlänge beträgt nur 0,3 Millimeter.
Das ist absolut nichts!
Ein Reiskorn sieht im Vergleich dazu riesig
aus!
Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Hier gibt es täglich faszinierende Wissenschaftsvideos.
Abonniert den Kanal!
Nur dann verpasst ihr nichts!
Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen!
Entwickelt wurde der Miniminiminicomputer
im Rahmen eines nerdigen Duells zwischen den
Ingenieuren und Ingenieurinnen von IBM und
der Universität aus Michigan: Immer wieder
übertrumpfen sie sich beim Bau des kleinsten
Computer der Welt.
Doch jetzt steht tatsächlich die Frage im
Raum, ob der neu entwickelte Chip überhaupt
als vollwertiger Computer zählt!
Der Hintergund: Von 2014 bis Anfang 2018 hielt
die University of Michigan den Weltrekord
für den kleinsten Computer der Welt.
Der sogenannte “Michigan Micro Mote” war
nur 2x2x4 Millimeter klein - dabei aber voll
funktionsfähig.
Nur noch mal, um seine Winzigkeit zu verdeutlichen:
In einen Fingerhut würden tatsächlich fast
150 dieser Mini-Computer passen.
Auch, wenn er nicht an Strom angeschlossen
war, konnte er seine Programmierung und Daten
speichern.
Und der “Michigan Micro Mote” gilt als
“vollständiges autonomes Computersystem”,
so die Pressemitteilung der Universität Michigan.
Die Anforderungen dafür erfüllt er tatsächlich
in jedem Punkt: Das Computersystem muss in
der Lage sein, Daten aufzunehmen, die eingegeben
werden.
Zudem muss er die Fähigkeit haben, diese
zu verarbeiten und zu speichern und Entscheidungen
darüber treffen können, was als Nächstes
zu tun ist.
Aufgebaut ist der der Mini-Computer in gestapelten
Schichten, die untereinander kommunizieren
können.
Zudem enthält er eine Solarzelle, die ihn
mit 20nW versorgt und alleine durch das Auffangen
des Umgebungslichtes kontinuierlich laufen
kann.
Im Standby-Modus verbraucht das Gerät etwa
eine Million Mal weniger Strom als ein herkömmliches
Handy im Standby-Modus.
Und auf seine Anwendung in verschiedenen Praxis-Bereichen
musste der Mini-Computer auch nicht lange
warten.
Das Michigan-Forschungsteam wurde überflutet
von Anfragen: Nicht nur Schnecken-Fachleute
zeigten sich interessiert, sondern auch Experten
aus dem medizinischen Bereich.
Auf der Basis des Mini-Computers wurde beispielsweise
bereits injizierbare Sensorsysteme entwickelt,
die direkt aus dem menschlichen Körper senden
können.
Doch dann kam im Februar 2018 der Gegenschlag
von IBM.
Der Durchmesser hier: nur 1x1 Millimeter mit
mehreren hunderttausend Transistoren, also
elektronischen Halbleiter-Elementen.
Wirklich krass klein, denn der IBM-Mini-Rechner
ist kleiner als ein grobkörniges Salzkorn.
Doch seine Leistung ist für diese “Größe”
enorm und vergleichbar mit der eines x86-PCs
aus den 90er Jahren.
Aber hey: Die Desktop-Computer von damals
waren nicht nur riesig, sondern auch unhandlich
und schwer.
Wirklich beeindruckend, was sich in den Jahren
getan hat!
Laut den IBM-Entwicklern soll seine Herstellung
weniger als zehn Euro kosten.
Und IBM hat Großes mit ihm vor: Er könnte
in viele gängige Konsumgüter integriert
werden und Produkte so fälschungssicher machen.
Jetzt hat die Universität Michigan allerdings
wieder zurückgeschlagen.
Ihr neu entwickelter Computer hat nur eine
Kantenlänge von 0,3 Millimetern und ein Reiskorn
sieht im direkten Vergleich mit einem Computer
aus wie ein Riese.
Mit integriert: Prozessoren, Photovoltaik
sowie Funksender und -empfänger.
Er ist in der Lage Temperaturen in Zeitintervalle
umzuwandeln.
Durch den Vergleich mit einem konstanten Zeitintervall
kann er so die Temperatur bis auf 0,1 Grad
Celsius genau bestimmen.
Und ihr könnt es Euch sicher schon denken:
Eine großartige Anwendungsmöglichkeit für
den Mini-Rechner wäre der medizinische Bereich.
Er könnte beispielsweise Temperaturveränderungen
in Zellgruppen messen und somit Tumore aufspüren.
Denn es gibt Studien, die nahelegen, dass
Krebs-Tumore höhere Temperaturen als reguläres
Gewebe aufweisen.
Das müsste natürlich alles erst noch genau
getestet werden.
Doch zurück zu dem Computer selbst, denn
da gibt es noch eine kuriose Sache zu berichten:
Sowohl bei der IBM-Entwicklung als auch bei
dem neuen Produkt aus Michigan sind sich Experten
gar nicht so sicher, ob diese beiden Mini-Computer
überhaupt als solche bezeichnet werden könnten.
Denn im Gegensatz zu dem “Michigan Mirco
Mote” verlieren sie ihre früheren Programmierungen
und Daten, sobald ihnen der Strom fehlt.
Dazu David Blauuw, ein Experte für Elektrotechnik:
“"Wir sind nicht sicher, ob sie Computer
genannt werden können oder nicht.
Es ist eher so etwas wie eine Auslegungssache,
ob sie tatsächlich die erforderliche Mindestfunktionalität
haben.”
Dabei ist eine Sache dennoch ganz sicher:
Durch das nerdige Duell der beiden Konkurrenten
in den USA entstehen so immer neue Entwicklungen
und Techniken, die uns früher oder später
auch im Alltag enorm weiterhelfen könnten.
Und jetzt: Hier klicken!
Das war nämlich eine Videopremiere auf dem
englischen Clixoom-Kanal.
Wenn ihr alle Videos auf jeden Fall zuerst
sehen wollt, dann abonniert Clixoom auf jeden
Fall auch auf englisch.
Ich freue mich auf euch auch dort!
Stay tuned, see you soon!